I'm well I hate them I love talking
about them you like talking about I'm
this is a kind of a somewhat recent
conversion for me I've never bought into
any diet fad or any of these hippie seed
oils are of the devil they are the cause
of every problem in the world wow almost
almost I would say 99 I am so I'm so one
over on this now your wife is a doctor
so obviously you know that well I mean I
assumed it was crap but then I just
missed it like every other stupid idea
that I ever heard also I'm sick of
people making products from things that
don't produce that product naturally
oats are not for milk and and I never
get down on them neither neither are
almonds and neither are soybeans no as
it turns out none of these things
produce milk and so if you give me a
glass of milk that is made from a thing
that doesn't produce milk I am
suspicious